history making a first for you what was
going through your head when they
announced your names
what
you know what's crazy before i got
drafted yeah david stern did that same
thing
and look down
because they have to make sure they say
my name right sometimes so it's kind of
like similar uh
to see tyra you know react before she
said like whoa
yeah like whoa like how he do this
but i i just at that moment all i could
think was you know i wonder what my mom
is saying right now
the reason i did the show was because
she loves this show she loves what it
represents
what it does for people
the other side other side that it shows
in an athlete
an entertainer period and
my dad testing positive for kobe they
weren't allowed to be here in the
ballroom tonight
but it came to every show they come to
every show they love this franchise they
love this brand they was here right now
they'd be smiling trying to do the
interviews with me
i love y'all i miss y'all y'all gonna
get the whole list soon put it in the
cage with the rest of it
where are you gonna put the mirror ball
your mom and dad's gonna get it yeah we
put them in the cage i only take them on
a walk here and there
you got it you're a really cool guy
yeah man you got to keep you keep your
trophy in the cage man you can't just be
taking it on a walk all the time man uh
iman you're a really cool guy was there
ever a concern that you might become a
meme
any moment where you like i don't want
to do that i mean i hope i become a meme
man you know meet me up
honestly it's uh
i'm really big on
you know
seeing something and saying
i don't like how that looks but also
understanding
well it wouldn't look like that if i
didn't
i try and all the time walk like me talk
like me uh
i try and do things where it's my happy
medium yeah man
the coolest thing dancing with the stars
could have done was pair me with this
one here yes cause daniella
refuses to let me look awkward yes um
she's
thrown in so many different moves that
i know will get all those technicality
points and
if it makes me uncomfortable after
learning it if it's uncomfortable she'll
change it
because at the end of the day she thinks
the same way as my wife and
i'd rather give a performance y'all
never forget
than give a performance that's
technically correct that got us a good
score and off the show yeah um
again
thank you all for giving me dj yellow
oh my god and last name for life praying
for life what did it feel like to have
the whole nba rooting for you like i
literally got an espn notification okay
i was like really yeah
hey it's a fraternity it's a brotherhood
man
this is vice versa though man i still go
to those games and support those guys
it's a family basketball
uh something that raised half of us
brought us all together
uh helped us travel the world
it's never gonna stop for me as far as
you know
having that love and then showing that
love on the other side so to all my nba
brothers that that voted
that pushed you following the vote uh
mello for calling in you didn't tell me
you did that uh
man it's a special moment i'm glad i
could share this with y'all awesome
thank you guys congratulations thank you
yes you guys see the trophy oh yeah we
want to get the trophy
it looks good
it looks good
[Laughter]
you